Speaker 1: Let's go to Rob from
Massachusetts. Rob, welcome to the show.
Speaker 3: All right. Thank you. First time on.
I have a really quick question. Sure. I have a
right wing friend at work and he tends to like
commenting on you. Two things I'm just saying,
as I have learned to think like he does
sort of a little version of him in my head,
like try to be a rational person. And I
wonder if that happens to you, if you find
it useful for arguments or if it's just shredding
because you know that I think like better than.
Speaker 1: No, that's real. It's really good
and it's useful. And I would argue that it's
actually quite healthy, which is okay. We
see a headline, gas prices down two months
in a row. I think it's great to say, okay, how
are how are Republicans going to react to this?
Do they have a point? If so, should I modify my
view? If not, why is it that they're actually
wrong? I mean, maybe gas prices is a bad
example, but I think that that's actually
very healthy. It's it's arguably a version
of Steele Manning, which is rather than straw
manning your political opponents, you steal
man and say, what's the best case I can make
for their view? And if I still think it's a bad
case, it reinforces that I've come to the right
conclusion. I think that's very healthy as long as
it doesn't become like intrusive or pathological.
Speaker 3: Right that those in the same area still
mounting. So I never support them. Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right, Rob, thank you very much.
That that last bit was a little garbled. I
didn't understand that, but I did understand.
Thank you. And I really do appreciate that